there are few more important tasks for
parents than to be able to listen
properly to their children that is pick
up on and give room to their children's
moods hatreds and enthusiasms
even when these run contrary to their
own inclinations
it's on the basis of having been
listened to with close sympathy and
imagination that a child will later on
be able to accept themselves remain in
touch with what they feel and find
partners who are interested in their
core selves
why should listening properly prove so
hard for many parents
partly because what children say and do
can prove so threatening to parents
sense of their identity we may as
parents have said a very firm goodbye to
vulnerability imagination frankness
sexual fluidity or sadness
but our children come into the world
unaware of any such repudiations
what we have put into our shadow sides
may lie in the midday sun of our
offspring's young lives
the kids have no compunction saying that
granny is a big fat poo that they want
to dress like an opposite gender or that
they long to live in a bigger house they
may in addition be terrible at maths and
hopeless at tying their own shoelaces
this may rattle us to the core
how could we have worked so hard to
expunge weakness from our personality
only for it to show up in the next
generation
how can they be so shockingly needy and
difficult so illogical and impolite
there can be jealousy behind much of the
resulting non-listening
parents may not take their children's
cries to heart because no one paid
particular attention to their own
lamentations
why would they be patient to another's
petty sorrows when they had to grow up
with brutal speed
the best way for parents to protect
themselves against registering their
latent frustrations and regrets can be
to ensure that their children also don't
get what they want
non-listening parents are to be found
constantly rewriting their children's
experiences
that's nonsense they will say i know you
love going for walks in the rain or why
would my brave little soldier cry about
something like that or they'll insinuate
that there is simply no way to devote
oneself to something ballet or business
being shy or dressing as a fairy and
remain legitimate and lovable
the legacy of not being listened to is a
split personality in which we are unable
to allow in the sadness or anger
vulnerability or confidence that our
parents once denied in us
properly growing up may involve asking
ourselves a very unfamiliar question
what sides of me could my parents not
accept
and making friends with the answers
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed the concept of emotional
inheritance the formation of our
concepts of being good or bad and the
impact of parental styles of love on the
way we choose adult partners